should we talk now like I don't think we
actually talked about dating don't date
feminists no we didn't talk about dating
and don't taste famous can I talk about
my book for a minute
yeah absolutely I can show it I think
okay I hope the only reason I want to
bring it I don't want to talk about my
book is that that's boring but but your
book is offensive it is offensive is the
tactical guide to women's than the most
it's a misogynistic sounding title but
if you get in you read the internet even
if you read as much as a subtitle it
starts to come into focus this is not a
misogynistic book but the reason I wrote
this book is because I found in my
clinical practice so many guys ending up
in family court or divorced or just
miserable at home or alcoholic or or you
know addicted to two different things or
having anxieties or as a depression and
so much of it comes back to the choice
of the the women that they bring into
their lives and so I wrote a book that
that apparently guide to women yeah it's
it's been well received apparently where
I talk a lot about how to vet women for
you know who you can allow into your
inner circle you know you should be a
very selective about who you allow and
tear in a circle especially someone
who's in such an intimate position as as
a female partner
Magnusson my first question is have they
written smears about this book because I
can just see how easy would be to write
shockingly no I've been I've I actually
was hoping that some some radical angry
feminists would give me some free
publicity but right really not much to
object to in here and I'm saying right
men should be selective and they should
look for character well if you argue
against that you sort of indicted
yourself as someone who's not worthy of
being in someone else but it's men
centric yes I just imagine so so maybe
it's coming I didn't I just haven't
encountered it yet so well you explained
basically the gist of it but I don't
know if you want to elaborate I guess
because we can get into the hard don't
take feminists but I want to we can we
can ease into that or we can just jump
off the diving board well I can I can
give you the gist of the book is that
there are some basic characteristics
that you should look for including
shared values and the ability things
like maturity and the ability to
navigate relationships and conflict and
so forth guys are not really taught to
look for these things women are very
good at I well they're marginally better
than us at
talking to their daughters about the
character of the men that they bring
into the life a good point when I ask
men who taught you how to select women
the answer is always just the blank
stare nobody taught him and so they
emulate what they see or they just
follow their instinct or I was walking
past a TV Target or something and there
was some sort of dating reality show and
this I just caught a clip of this guy
saying talking about a woman and saying
well it'll happen when it happens and
all no one that's right and that is such
a powerless way to make decisions about
me one of the most important decisions
you're going to make in your life if
you're thinking about marriage and I
thought to myself that guy's going to
Family Court I'm just talking about but
I know he's going to Family Court at
some point and so the book is really to
help men make intelligent decisions
about who they bring into life so
getting back to dating feminism well
it's the first chapter one don't date a
feminist no I don't I don't talk about
the negative side and so much the things
to avoid because that stuff is out there
you know the 14 red flags to avoid any
yeah and now that's marginally useful
but what's more useful is knowing what
to look for well you know looking for
signs of character maturity and the
ability to navigate difficulties and and
how men and women function well together
generally and the first part of the book
actually answer your question is a lot
about your mission you as the reader
because mission is so important to a
man's life like nothing works if you
don't have your mission in order your
job doesn't work your relationships
don't work and so my first three
chapters are about you know let's let's
get your act together before you even
think about who you bring into your life
clean your own room before you try to
change the world who said that Jordan
Peter yeah but yeah yeah so so then what
what is it specifically about feminists
and then and I'll clarify to you it's
the the woke intersectional like right
you know a more extreme yeah not the not
the person who calls herself a feminist
because she believes in accountability
and so right Theo you should date that
person provided the values are lined up
and she has all the other prerequisites
yeah but the the angry bitter sad
victimized feminists that the most
obvious problem with dating anybody who
has an ideology that says I'm the
and I'm being mistreated is that once
the honeymoon is over guess who the
oppressor is because this person has to
have an oppressor yeah and if this
person is thinking that men in general
are my oppressor and then the honeymoon
starts to fade which is somewhere
between 12 and 18 months our brain
chemistry starts to to reach its
baseline and we start to see the other
person's a real person not as an
idealized person then at that point and
I've seen this like clockwork when when
couples come in and the woman has a
identitarian feminist ideology that that
finds its way into the relationship and
I don't see that a whole lot because
frankly there's not a lot of hardcore
feminists off campus and functioning in
the real world because it's such a
dysfunctional way of going through the
world that people don't have much
tolerance for it other than on campus
you're celebrating on campus but it
always finds its way into the
relationship and then the man becomes
the oppressor and you can't argue with
somebody constructively if they think
that you are mistreating them at every
turn right do you think there's an
inverse to that like is there a version
for women you could say like is there
certain men they shouldn't date yeah
they should actually written the same
thing toxic feminist male yeah I wrote a
book called the practical guide to min
it's gotten a lot less precedent the
tactical guide to women has done very
well for me so it's clearly filling some
kind of an issue out there but yeah
there are there are men that women
probably shouldn't date well going
through the checklist you know he has to
be able to navigate difficulties and he
should probably be a little bit stoic so
he can handle things and he should have
his mission in order because if he
doesn't have his mission in order then
you don't really know who you're dating
and this is more characteristic of men
than women that men need to have that in
place to be able to function well that's
interesting because I've I've never
heard it from you know clinical or an
academic standpoint but I've always
described my mission that way like I
have a mission I have a plan I know what
I'm doing and I'm navigating various
paths but I've always my entire life had
a quest that I've been on and I wonder
if that is is one of the reasons why
millennial men have
then maybe maybe it's fair to be so hard
on them as I am but so many have kind of
been like lost or ineffective or
reclusive it's because they've never
found their mission yeah in in you know
in reference that they as we mentioned
Jordan Peterson one of the things I've
said in the past is that I think Jordan
Peterson fills the role of a loss of
purpose because we've become so
comfortable and successful in our lives
so now you have people who are lost to
have nothing to live for
and he says find the heaviest thing you
can and carry it yes and that's them
finding their mission yes and then to
bring it back to dating mmm I wonder if
one of the reasons if there's like a
causational or correlational effect
between a lot of these women who hate
men and being surrounded by ineffective
mission --less men so then they in turn
resent them and think men are bad right
how could you not resent somebody if
you're if you're in that position and
you're with somebody that you know that
well you don't know that but I take it
as a given that a man has to have his
mission in order for his life to
function correctly and if he's not
taking care of himself which is getting
his mission order keeping his body in
order you know having some sense
something that he's working toward how
could you not get a little bit resentful
towards someone like that oh yeah so so
in turn women shouldn't date men without
a mission or is there a better way or
well my situation because young guys in
their 20s you know they're not all like
you and maybe maybe part of what you see
among Millennials is that young guys in
general have to struggle a little bit
most of us have to struggle a little bit
to find our mission so it can look like
a guy in his 20s as aimless when really
he's working pretty hard to figure out
where he's going he just doesn't have
his direction yet and that that really
stinks about being in your 20s for most
guys is that you are and at a position
where now you are expected your man
you're expected to know where you're
going but you don't know where you're
going yet yeah and it's a tough place to
be in I mean I feel like when I was in
my 20s my early 20s I was you know
bouncing around I was in LA I was
briefly homeless I you know moved across
the country couple times but I still had
a mission and I know it's not like I had
a mad road map where I'm like I'm gonna
be here in five years was kind of like I
must remain focused you were going
forward
right exactly yeah so you know to the
outside
you know viewer it might seem like guy
was aimless right but to me it was like
I'm you know essentially putting out
feelers and trying to figure out what
where the path is yeah and I bet that
was apparent to anyone who was watching
you at the time yeah I guess maybe yeah
I was always doing stuff you know III
book right before I went down in New
York for Occupy Wall Street I was
actually starting to make youtube skate
videos and then went to you know Occupy
Wall Street and then that kind of
changed everything but I was always
trying to figure out what should I be
doing what can I be doing you know so so
to bring it back to you know the dating
thing soups I don't on TV too much
there's an interesting idea that a lot
of people have talked about in that when
all of these women younger women are
surrounding themselves with weak men
nice guys angry guys men who are abiding
by like say what the American
Psychological Association they're gonna
read the same yeah you have men who are
following this this feminist sort of
doctrine of how you should behave you
shouldn't be stoic should let your
emotions and then they end up getting
angry at you know the women for not
behaving the way they expect and behave
the women then say all men are bad right
because they're surrounded by them yeah
so these these feminist types are
surrounded by these weak ineffective
nice guys who make them angry and
resentful and that's because it's the
only men they see then say you know all
men are abusers all matter this way or
most men tend to be so then when you see
like if something I saw on Twitter a
while ago when I started looking at the
mean that was reset the clock when male
feminists turn out to be abusers it's
like well no wonder feminists think all
men are bad they've surrounded
themselves by these feminists men who
are bad so now that's their that's their
world with the experience the feminist
men that you're asserting and I wouldn't
disagree that they have that nice guy
right cluster of behaviors that covert
sort of aggression and and just right
it's that bitterness well it's like you
you have these guys who they're not
necessarily weak but they think they're
on the right path and then when they
find out they're not they get really
angry it's like it's like would you
would you mention for like a cost
fallacy that you've invested so much
into this some cost about some cost of
housing you've invested so much into
this that now that's backfire
on you you're furious you're angry and
so now these feminists are surrounded by
these men who are seeing its backfire
yeah like you men you you you see so
many um I don't want to get too much
into it but you know with with polyamory
I can respect honest polyamory to it to
a certain extent but you have a lot of
instances of what people refer to as a
cook right yes and that's that's one of
the things that you know I I have worked
with the kink community because what
happened early in my practice is someone
came in and they were part of the kink
community and I got really curious like
how does this work because I feel like I
didn't know how how to really work with
the specifics of their situation so I
said show me around take me so I went to
some dungeons and I went to some clubs
and I started talking to people and
figuring out how this works in some part
of it I can wrap my head around
polyamory is one that I really have
trouble wrapping my head around from a
male perspective because exactly
I cannot even fathom sharing my wife
with anybody I'm toxic I guess I'm very
possessive like the thought of it just
it kind of makes me a little crazy so
it's up to your point I well yes I did
it but this is something you typically
will see more among the feminists to the
left so I have to I can only imagine why
would a woman need to go to another man
to be satisfied there's well I think
that's I don't think there's a single
answer that I think people like variety
and yeah there's that's a big factor but
I get what you're I get what you're
you're moving toward here that there's
something she's not getting at home yeah
yeah and I want to make sure it's clear
I'm not saying everyone is uniform
everybody has some a preferences right I
have a bunch of friends who are you know
don't like I have a few friends who are
dominatrixes what's the pluralist and
people who are in decay and can BDSM and
I'm super little a libertarian like you
do you you'd be happy yeah but what I
think you know what I'm trying to get at
is that there's at least a subset of men
who are weak effeminate and resentful
and angry because everything they've
been taught to do didn't work yes and so
then these other women are like I'm
gonna go somewhere else and not give it
to you so they get really angry yeah and
say it's actually interesting I remember
when I was really young I remember
experiencing something like this you see
in all of these movies and romantic
comedies the chivalrous man milady doing
all
nice things and it's like not the way
your people are supposed to act
that guy's repulsive right exactly he's
attractive at first but down the road
he's repulsive because what does he
stand for he stands for pleasing
everybody that's not an attractive
quality agreeableness yeah so I guess
the question is someone like that would
just bend the knee to anybody and
they're not gonna take charge and defend
you when the bear shows up they're gonna
be like whatever you want bear you eat
them actually reminds me of what what
was it there's a movie coming out with I
think Will Ferrell and it's like him and
his wife are at a ski resort and they're
doing a controlled Avalanche so they
have these these pipes that blast out
you know it's like it fires like a
backfire whatever I don't know would you
call it which makes the snow you know go
nuts so when the Avalanche starts he
ditches his family and runs and hides
and this causes a familial dispute where
she was like you ran and left us behind
like she expected her husband to try and
protect and save the family but he
dashed away so I guess I bring this up
because it's like it in now in a
mainstream movie the plot point is that
men should be traditional but that's
toxic and the wife is actually mad so I
guess I don't know I think it's
interesting that we have this sort of
duality or maybe dwell is not the right
word but paradox in mainstream pop
culture where you have all of these
things saying men should behave a
certain way but then you simultaneously
have other movies screaming not to
behave a certain way right how can
anyone figure out what they're supposed
to do yeah I think the answer is you
ignore it all and you do what you wanted
you do not I want to be careful I say
it's not necessarily what you want to do
because what you want to do is not
necessarily something that's gonna bring
you meaning but one of the things that
every young guy has to figure out is how
is he gonna put a dent in the universe
is one of my friends says um how is he
going to do something that he can look
back on that's the much more important
question is you can do something that's
difficult and valuable not necessarily
fun
maybe it's fun too but but I think a lot
of guys want legacy and so that's why a
lot of these guys who go down the path
that is incorrect become extremely
dangerous and violent their path to
legacy is evil yeah
but they was in there a very small group
right right of course but yeah that's
that's the extreme if this if this
contradiction and this ideology is taken
to its extreme that's where we end up
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts everyday after the show we make
them available in the community section
of this YouTube channel so don't forget
to subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you